they could never have imagined a reunion
as bittersweet as this
for a few minutes one ukrainian family
are together again at a bus station in
warsaw then it's goodbye
daughters katarina and alina fled from
kiev a few days ago but their parents
who were in cuba on holiday when the war
broke out are only passing through the
bus station now on their way back into
ukraine
i don't want to stay in the safety of
poland she says i want to go home
katarina makes the sign of the cross
towards her father
it's the most horrible thing she says
anything could happen
it could be the last time i see my
parents
people are being directed towards
transport to take them to other polish
cities and across europe
vladimir putin's war is scattering
refugees near and far this group have
just got off a bus from central ukraine
they're now waiting to be taken to spain
a country none of them have any
connection with but somewhere which has
offered to take them in
for now this boy seeks his mother's love
but when he's older he'll remember this
who made them flee across europe who
made their lives hell
martyr aged 15 is already angry
i won't be in ukraine i won't be in my
home i won't be with my friends i won't
be with my family i won't be with my dad
with my dog i won't be with my family
keira waits with her mother and her toy
pig to be called forward to get on a
coach to estonia
there's no father figure to carry her
heavy bag the men have stayed in ukraine
to fight
her mother says i just want the wall to
stop that's all i want
then we see a bus which will cross
europe on its way to the british seaside
town of bournemouth though visa
restrictions mean only ukrainians with
family will be allowed to stay on the
bus until its final destination
on board this woman and her children
heading to france struggled over broken
bridges under gunfire to escape from
urpin nikkiev
she says her husband was so afraid for
them he forced them to go
[Music]
it's so bizarrely incongruous to hear
background music piped around the coach
as she describes running for their life
met by friends this beautician arrived
from the city of sumi she says there was
no water food or electricity
putin is in his bunker she says
sarcastically he's fine and he's smiling
there are few smiling here
warsaw bus station a sad scene of
separation and despair
lisa holland sky news warsaw